a big immigration debate is underway on
Capitol Hill Mitch McConnell is saying
that you only have one week to do the
whole thing for the dreamers and I'm
telling you watching this thing the
same-old open border suspects are at it
again
front and center is Senator Dick Durbin
he took to the Senate floor yesterday to
repeat that tedious trope that you
Americans are just too lazy or unwilling
to do the jobs that only illegal
immigrants will do go to the local meat
processing plant or the chicken
processing plant and watch who comes out
of that plant that quit in time
Hispanics and Africans taking what are
pretty tough dirty rough jobs because
others don't want them not many of us
say to our sons and daughters I'm hoping
the day will come when you decide to go
and pick fruit for a living
hardly ever hear that because we know
it's hard back-breaking work and
immigrants do the work now that is so
offensive on so many levels we could
spend an hour debunking it and analyzing
it just for my own personal experience
my brothers my mother and I did all of
these jobs we did manual labor fruit
picking paper routes lawn work cutting
lawns raking lawns restaurant work my
mother waited tables into her early 70s
and if she were alive I think about her
a lot I think she'd probably show up at
Durbin's office to throw one of her old
polyester uniforms at him should be so
mad I'll tell you what's really going on
in this whole debate the Democrats don't
really care all that much about these
illegal workers as much as they care
about getting their power back now what
do I mean we know a lot of middle-class
voters are fed up with the Democrats so
the party has to begin to remake the
electorate but Durbin statement ignores
the fact that the inflow of all this
cheap immigrant labor hurts Americans
who actually will do those jobs that
Durbin turns his nose up at here's how
my radio callers reacted
his comments today I was in a position
where I just really needed a job and I
went around to these locations that Vic
said were the Hispanics like in the
restaurants for example in the kitchen
and I couldn't get my foot in the door
I've got 38 years experience and heavy
demolition and I've got turned down for
three jobs because I don't speak Spanish
now for a fair wage Americans will do
and have done these jobs Senator Durbin
so stop lying to us preserving
entry-level work opportunities for
Americans is important for young people
and it's also really important for those
who don't have a college degree maybe
for those who don't have a special skill
set developed and I think it's really
interesting to look back to see how the
Democrats have shifted on the
immigration issue I remember the time
when Democrats actually supported the
working men and women of the country and
they even worried about flooding the
nation with poor people from other
countries who were going to compete with
poor people already in our country who
are American citizens or legal
immigrants twenty-five years ago this
was Dianne Feinstein Mexico does nothing
to enforce its border it is my view that
if we are going to have a North American
Free Trade Agreement that Mexico must do
its share because the day when America
could be the welfare system for Mexico
is gone you have to concentrate on
saying the people we should be here are
those who come legally at this time what
happened to that guy Feinstein that's
sounds like Jeff Sessions a couple of
years ago when he was in the Senate
imagine if a Republican made that
comment about the welfare state today
there be howls from the lamestream media
and from Democrats how can you say that
that was Feinstein amazing and this was
Bernie Sanders 11 years ago who spoke
out and voted against george w bush's
push for amnesty I think it's high time
that the Senate of
United States of America began to stand
up for the American worker and I would
hope that before an immigration bill is
passed that it will respect the rights
of American workers both low-wage
workers and both professional workers
look Sanders was right where is the
congressional concern for the human
dignity of America's low-skilled workers
today they call them the working poor
middle class lower middle class people
and people could support families on
these jobs and they could live decent
lives and look in certain with limited
circumstances in particular industries
guest workers do make sense but it
shouldn't become the norm certainly
doesn't have to be and I was thinking
about this as well it would be nice if
just once in a blue moon we heard
someone like a senator durbin oh really
anyone speak in such emotional terms on
the Senate floor about the innocent
Americans who lost their jobs or their
lives at the hands of illegal immigrants
case in point on Sunday an illegal
immigrant Jose Duran Romero slammed into
an ambulance carrying a mother and her
three year-old boy in winston-salem
North Carolina
his blood level alcohol blood level was
double the legal limit he injured the
mother and the driver and the little boy
is dead how many innocent lives have to
be lost before the US Congress focuses
on the well-being of American citizens
and legal immigrants rather than kowtow
into la raza and the business lobby
we're all waiting as this is another
good thing dick Durbin of course has the
luxury of having a job that can't be
taken by an illegal immigrant at least
not yet maybe he needs a little taste of
his own medicine there he can compete
with the legal labor to even stay in the
Senate but whatever Congress's final
deal on immigration includes if it ends
up being a deal at all the needs of the
American people the American worker
should all
be priority number one and that's the
angle